agressif et violent même avec vous
violent
mais parce que parce que quand on est
sous l'emprise de la drogue et de
l'alcool on est plus le même homme c'est
pour ça que j'ai toujours pardonné j'ai
jamais essayé de le juger et j'ai jamais
essayé de le changer c'est un c'est la
vie qu'on a partagé qui est
toutes les épreuves qu'on a vécues qui
ont changé un homme
et le temps et lui il s'est beaucoup
remis en question et puis il a pris à
faire un travail sur le pardon
alors merci d'être là on a Myriam
Palomba bien entendu spécialiste de tous
les divorce tout et couple bien sûr
actuellement et on a mettre Roland Perez
un ponte que j'adore en plus mais merci
Roland d'être avec nous à vocal
historique de Sylvie Vartan qui a
beaucoup suivi les procès qui ont
déchiré la famille à l'idée c'était
l'ex-femme de Johnny Hallyday alors
merci à vous deux d'être là et samedi
soir sur France 2 c'est un petit
événement parce que quelle époque
recevait Laetitia à l'idée donc il s'est
livré comme rarement ça a bien marché ce
qu'on a les audiences s'il vous plaît
merci
toujours ça bouge pas en fait
merci alors on sait Johnny était un
homme d'excès notamment avec moi j'étais
fou de Johnny je le dis voilà je le
cache pas et rien ne pourra
salir mon Johnny rien ne vous dit rien
on peut me dire tout sur Johnny à [ __ ]
je l'aime je l'aimerai toujours c'est
incroyable voilà et ce conseil moi c'est
qu'il pouvait aussi lui arriver je sais
pas c'est quoi cette histoire un des
extraits qui a fait le plus parlé
regardez
les infidélités c'était quoi c'était
dans les deux sens c'était tout le temps
tous les deux c'est lui qui a commencé
et vous avez répondu je me suis
abandonnée je me suis j'ai oublié que
j'avais un mari j'ai oublié je pensais
que tout était acquis alors que rien
n'était acquis que rien n'est jamais
acquis dans un couple ça m'a donné des
grandes leçons donc je me suis vengé
pour pour me montrer que je pouvais
encore séduire et que je pouvais plaire
et que et j'ai eu un moment de faiblesse
puis l'as su et comment il a réagi je
vous demande pas parce qu'il a très très
mal beaucoup plus mal que moi mais ouais
c'est chaud c'est chaud
leur couple a été rythmée par les
diverses fidélités alors qu'à un moment
elle a dit ouais ce qu'elle dit c'est
que voilà elle s'est dit ouais je vais
je vais essayer de séduire
quand même que Laetitia aurait eu je
vais quand même utiliser une aventure
avec Lenny Kravitz voilà donc c'est
quelque chose que Lenny Kraviz elle
avait d'ailleurs été assise
et la fidélité dont elle parle dans le
documentaire non enfin là oui
certainement mais et lui il aurait aussi
trompé plusieurs reprises et notamment
cette histoire là mais la femme dont
elle parle notamment chez Léa Salamé
qu'elle remercie de d'avoir de l'avoir
aidé à reconstruire son couple après
s'être tromperie est aussi une jeune
femme que certains peuvent connaître
puisqu'elles s'appellent Vanessa et elle
avait fait la Une à l'époque d'un
célèbre magazine People et cette jeune
femme était connue notamment pour avoir
participé à une émission de téléréalité
opération séduction Caraïbes sur M6 donc
voilà
non non c'est pas ça mais bon donc voilà
donc voilà c'est ça couple effectivement
qui n'était pas
fidèle l'un envers
alors non
elle était quand même au courant que
Johnny allait voir à droite à gauche de
façon assez régulière
elle s'est un peu laissée aller parce
qu'elle s'occupait de
la de sa grand-mère
de de Jade ou effectivement elle s'est
beaucoup concentrée sur son rôle de
maman donc là elle a vraiment commencé à
délaisser Johnny enfin en tout cas et
c'est comme ça qu'il l'a ressenti et
puis quand elle a accueilli sa
belle-mère et sa grand-mère à elle chez
elle ou elle a joué effectivement tous
les jours les infirmières elle était
plus du tout dans son rôle de jeunes
femmes sexy aimante et Johnny ce serait
senti délaissé et on aurait profité pour
la tromper à l'appel ça a vraiment de
façon très régulière c'est fou ça et
c'est pour ça qu'elle remercie justement
cette jeune femme parce que ça lui a
donné un envie de ce de ce magnifique de
se faire sexy à nouveau
vous pouvez me demander les problèmes de
couple je connais tout
[Rires]
ça c'était connu ça c'était hyper connu
on le savait dans la presse oui je
savais effectivement qu'il y avait ces
histoires là et que et que et que s'est
trompé et je sais même qu'à la fin de
leur vie mais après c'est Jean-Claude
Camus pardon mais que je voyais beaucoup
qui me disait qu'à la fin de leur vie il
n'avait mangé une relation qui n'avait
plus de relation sexuelle des dernières
années ensemble que c'était un coup
fusionnel mais que et pour plein de
raisons parce qu'il buvait beaucoup
parce que du coup il était moins et que
voilà et que elle elle avait un petit
amant à côté mais qui était bien
ensemble voilà il le savait qu'elle
avait un petit amant oui comme quelle
taille
il le prenait très mal et en même temps
il couchait plus ensemble d'accord non
mais c'est sûr qu'il savait Gilles
Verdez
pour Fatou on te parle de nécessaire
[Applaudissements]
quand elle a su qu'elle était trompée
elle n'a rien dit et lui il a super mal
pris c'est ça qu'elle dit c'est qu'il y
avait déséquilibre quand même oui il a
très mal réagi et effectivement alors
c'est pas directement lié au sein de
violence qu'elle décrit parce qu'elle
décrit aussi des scènes de violence sous
alcool et drogues mais cortisone et
cortisone mais il y a eu des scènes de
violence donc j'ai trouvé que dans cette
interview elle se livrait vraiment alors
c'est vrai que depuis la mort du
chanteur la famille s'est déchiré entre
le clan Laetitia le clan David et Laura
et pour Laetitia il y a une raison à
tout ça Johnny et malheureusement partie
sans avoir pu régler ses problèmes avec
ces deux premiers enfants c'est ce
qu'elle dit regardez
reconnecter avec Laura non non
j'aimerais beaucoup
un pas après l'autre on avance mais le
seul qui pourrait apaiser et
et finalement guérir certaines blessures
et certaines rancœurs c'est Johnny les
plus là aujourd'hui et il a pas fait
avant de partir alors j'ai du mal à lui
en vouloir mais parfois
il y a des nuits où j'ai envie de hurler
et de lui dire mais Johnny revient
revient revient règle tes problèmes tu
m'as laissé tellement de choses sur mes
épaules règle tes problèmes
ensuite tu m'as laissé toutes les
emmerdes quoi
il n'a pas il n'a pas vraiment il a pas
osé dire à ses enfants avant de mourir
que voilà il leur il leur il est guérir
alors que le testament était fait depuis
depuis longtemps donc c'est vrai que
Johnny sur sur plusieurs aspects a été
lâche et ça faisait partie c'est un
aspect de sa personnalité assez
important il n'aimait pas voilà être
dans le conflit en tout cas pas direct
et souvent Laetitia était celle qui
devait se charger de régler les choses
déjà de son vivant
de Laetitia il lui offre une très jolie
voiture c'est une Jaguar c'est
magnifique c'est ce qu'elle voulait elle
est très heureuse elle a la voiture avec
elle et en fait quand Johnny meurt bah
ça sonne et bonjour il faut la récupérer
la partenaire à la banque c'était un
leasing et payer tous les mois elle
était à son nom et voilà c'est Johnny
lui avait pas acheté cette voiture pour
elle il prenait tout tout tout tout tout
à crédit des leasings et elle a dû tout
rendre Roland mais Johnny Johnny a
toujours vécu avec des dettes immenses
de société Johnny Hallyday et tout ce
qui peut faire Johnny Hallyday et ben tu
sais c'est compensé par quoi c'était
Johnny Hallyday donc Johnny Hallyday
c'est un animal moi je l'ai connu
moi je l'ai connu plein de fois en boîte
et tout ça c'est on ne conteste pas si
tu veux un mec de sa de sa stature c'est
dire que je dis pas pour autant qu'il
doit avoir un régime particulier ou
qu'on doit tout lui pardonner mais c'est
c'était comme ça Johnny Hallyday voilà
tu que tu vis avec Johnny Hallyday tu
vis pas avec le mec du coin qui on dit
attention dis donc tu as regardé la
femme d'à côté non il y avait quand même
quelqu'un qui était quand même très très
dur et très souvent sadique notamment
avec Laetitia et les femmes
oui je suis sûr de ça il y a même des il
y a eu des il y a des scènes par exemple
ou il se retrouve sur un bateau avec
Laetitia m'insulter son père et là elle
vient le voir en lui disant écoute
Mamour tu as été perdu
avec papa et qu'est-ce qu'il fait il la
jette par dessus par dessus bord il y a
une aussi une autre sèche il y a aussi
une autre scène où carrément il agresse
avec un pistolet à colle et c'est son
ami Marc Lancet qui vient qui vient des
dramatiser la situation et qu'il n'y a
calmer un peu les esprits parce qu'il
l'appelle en lutin écoute j'ai peur de
faire une bêtise
on vous entendez tout ça vous étiez
enfin on va parler de l'héritage déjà on
en est où Dieu du procès sur l'héritage
tout est réglé ou pas tout est
extrêmement bien réglé depuis déjà fort
longtemps donc oui les enfants ont
renoncé finalement cet héritage
certainement juste raison ils ont
renoncé David
non je crois que David ne voulait
voulait que tout revienne en France pour
pour quand même conserver une sorte de
droit moral sur sur les œuvres de son
père pour le reste il ne cherchait pas à
avoir de l'argent et chercher juste à ce
le droit français puissent s'appliquer
et je crois que c'est même chose pour
pour le rat donc tout est très bien
réglé c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont ils ont
renoncé à l'héritage mais je pense qu'on
a eu de l'argent quand même mais la
renoncé à l'héritage
je sais pas combien seul je suis parent
je suis pas dans les secrets de ce qui a
été fait parce que c'est une transaction
confidentielle mais en tout cas
a eu un million et demi plus un million
parce qu'elle a eu la part de son frère
voilà pour l'héritage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais comment tu sais tout ça
[Rires]
ce qui est important c'est que c'est que
elle a voulu cet héritage elle l'a
demandé elle s'est battue pour l'avoir
elle a vécu 24 ans avec un homme elle a
été à la source même de l'organisation
de cet héritage qui dans un premier
temps aller échapper au fisc français et
à la loi française pour aller aux
États-Unis et puis finalement est revenu
par la force des des
héritiers qui David et Laura se sont
battus pour eux ils se sont battus aussi
pour les petites puisqu'elles étaient
aussi en dehors de l'héritage donc il
faut savoir que elle s'est battue pour
cet héritage elle l'a voulu et
aujourd'hui venir un peu cracher dans la
soupe pardon et venir dire que
finalement il lui a laissé que des
soucis et que il aurait dû régler les
problèmes je pense que c'est pardon mais
je crois que c'est elle qui l'a aidé à
organiser de telle sorte qu'il y a eu
les problèmes alors elle a révélé aussi
que ils avaient comme projet d'adopter
un troisième enfant regarde
c'est vrai que vous avez voulu adopter
un troisième enfant un garçon pourquoi
ça s'est pas fait ça c'est fait mais on
n'a pas été au bout parce que je n'y est
tombé dans le coma on devait partir au
Vietnam
pour aller chercher ce petit garçon qui
était qui avait déjà un nom qui avait
été déjà qui existait déjà dans nos vies
la vie a basculé et on est il a été
plongé dans ce coma pendant un mois
après il y a une longue dépression
derrière et on a dû faire le deuil de
cet enfant c'est un petit garçon qui
s'appelait Shane
une vraie faut qu'elle donne on ne
savait pas que ils avaient fait toutes
ces démarches malheureusement Johnny est
tombé dans le coma ils ont dû et après
quand il en est sorti c'est suivi de
longue période de dépression ce qui a
fait qu'ils ont dû mettre fin à cette
procédure d'adoption alors si Laetitia
elle donne la raison
vous dites dans le documentaire que il
voulait absolument un enfant vous
n'arriviez pas à lui donner cette vous
avez essayé tout ce qui est possible
d'essayer vous n'arriviez pas il vous a
accompagné dans ces moments-là de femmes
vous vous passiez des chèques en échec
pour tomber enceinte il était là il
comprenait il était présent où il
réagissait comme non il était très très
présent il m'a porté il m'a accompagné
il m'a apaisé dans mes dans cette
culpabilité aussi que je vais porter de
pas pouvoir lui donner cet enfant dans
tirer voilà donc ça c'est vrai qu'elle a
alors là elle est plutôt sympa avec lui
parce que quand même il lui a quand même
au départ il lui a reproché il avait
vraiment très envie d'être père parce
qu'il avait un peu raté sa vie de papa
avec Laura et David et donc le fait
qu'elle puisse pas avoir d'enfant suite
à ces longs troubles d'anorexie fait que
lui il en a beaucoup beaucoup voulu au
départ quand même donc là l'épargne un
peu dans ses propos en disant qu'il a
qu'il a régulièrement accompagné c'était
ensuite quand ils ont commencé les
démarches d'adoption mais sur le coup
qui a été assez terrible pour lui puis
je revenir sur la dette parce que la
dette ça se joue là en fait ça se joue
le 15 décembre la dette fiscale on l'a
vu qui a été ramené le 34 à 30 millions
voilà elle est venue négocier Laetitia
avec le fils que français en mars ça
c'est pas bien passé en septembre ça
c'est mieux passé et là elle est revenue
aussi pour discuter avec le fils parce
que le 15 décembre elle doit régler la
première traite de cette dette qui a été
étalée le premier échéancier et on dit
que ce serait au tour d'un tiers à peu
près puisqu'elle avait vendu 30 millions
c'est 10 voilà puisqu'elle avait vendu à
peu près voilà parce que c'est la somme
globalement de la maison de Pacific
palissade qu'elle a vendu il va lui
servir à honorer la première traite et
autant elle a pu différer mais là le
fils lui a dit c'est 15 décembre le fils
veut que ce soit sur cette année 2022
c'est maintenant ou jamais voilà donc là
il va payer pour Noël oui elle continue
quand même à percevoir l'ensemble des
droits elle est quand même titulaire et
de l'intégralité des droits musicaux
que Johnny n'était pas auteur on est
compositeur de ça change
pour cent des droits d'édiction c'est
des chansons plusieurs millions je pense
oui ça représente je crois a priori à
peu près 1 million par an c'est ça de
donc 1 million plus tout ce qui se fait
autour de Johnny tout court
pendant un certain temps et
effectivement il y a cette maison de
Marnes-la-Coquette toute façon tout le
tout tout il faut savoir qu'elle a quand
même elle hormis la succession elle a
quand même 50% à en son nom propre et ça
en nom propre à la 50% des biens déjà
que ce soit aux États-Unis ou ceux qui
étaient situés en France elle a 50% des
des biens qui avaient été mis à son nom
dramatique
fou mais on va me tomber dessus c'est
que il y a quand même énormément de bien
immobilier
c'est qu'on parle systématiquement de
cette transaction avec le fisc c'est à
dire il faut trouver un accord parce
qu'évidemment ils vont payer à peu près
30 millions et Roland vous le savez la
vraie somme était bien supérieure à
celle là donc on trouve un accord comme
ça pour que tout le monde s'entende mais
pourquoi on trouve d'accord demain moi
je suis dans la merde avec les impôts
j'ai pas d'accord du tout d'accord
d'accords
parce que là il dit encore une énorme
connerie j'ai des potes moi qui sont pas
connus du tout qui ont eu des problèmes
avec labo qui ont trouvé des solutions
et on donne un peu là et après tu dis
des bêtises non non pas du tout mais
Castaldi il a trouvé il a trouvé un
accord entre un échéancier déjà et
baisser les montants
exactement
peuvent être n'importe quoi donc à
partir du moment où
une transaction peut intervenir c'est la
politique du fisco français
de malade mentale ça paraît bizarre qu'à
la fin tu dises j'ai tout dépensé
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on est d'accord
c'est c'est pareil pour tout le monde se
limite très bien pour moi
travail avant de revenir
il y a aujourd'hui des intérêts des
majorations des pénalités tout ça ça
peut être réduite ça peut être supprimé
si une transaction intervient et que le
fils qui est persuadé de percevoir en
face des potes sont tous les jours
office
tu peux demander bien sûr il en est
tellement de 75 euros 70 euros par mois
même à la fin il te fait cadeau enfin un
cadeau il t'enlève même 200 €, si tu
m'écoutes pas mais même quand on a un
contrôle fiscal on peut il y a une dette
on peut négocier cette dette avec l'État
avec lui s'il te plaît dis-lui un
contrôle fiscal on a une dette on peut
négocier cette dette avec ce que tu
penses de lui à la fin
et mérite bien sa place de deuxième
alors malgré les problèmes malgré les
difficultés qui sont plus traversées
dans leur couple Johnny manque encore
terriblement à Laetitia aujourd'hui
regardez si vous l'aviez en face de vous
là je vais dire qu'il me manque en
crever
et puis je lui dirai [ __ ] reviens
parce que tu m'as laissé avec beaucoup
d'emmerdes quoi tu viens rien régler ce
que des trucs que tu as pas géré mais en
même temps c'est toi et je t'aime comme
tu es et tu me manqueras toute ma vie
[Rires]
en fait par ce business comme ça de
l'intime de l'infidélité on a
l'impression on vit de les poubelles on
est dans la chambre
[Musique]
elle a pas toujours dit ça pendant
toutes ces années et juste après le
décès de Johnny elle le dit aujourd'hui
on se demande pourquoi sur la fidélité
ils en ont parlé tous les deux ensemble
dans une interview qu'ils avaient donné
à Paris Match
ils en avaient parlé ensemble donc je
trouve ça un peu
je veux bien juste apporter une
précision par rapport à ce que vous
disiez quand elle dit tu me manques elle
dit aussi que c'est vrai c'était
quasiment un couple à trois avec son
nouvel amour et ça c'est saisissant elle
dit ça elle dit à un moment pour lui
c'était dur parce qu'on a été trois
c'est fou quand même bah oui
mais c'est ce qu'elle dit que la
présence de Johnny c'était comme
si c'était très dur pour se
rencontrer
[Rires]